Hey youtubers, it's Charlie.
Thank you everyone that submitted questions for this week's Game of Thrones Q&A.
Good news too, because the winners of
the books haven't contacted me,
I'm kicking them back in in my episode 5
giveaway is going to be for the two signed copies
"A Feast for Crows" and "A Dance with Dragons"
Amongs, like, the many big questions that  you guys had, like,  R+L=J,
there are a lot of Barristan Selmy questions.
They kinda spoiled it in the promo for the next episode
Just in case you guys don't wanna know
anything about that I'm not going to
mention it in here.
Just carefull for spoilers if you haven't
seen last night's episode, so here we go...
First question:
Carolyn asks: "If ser Barristan or Grey Worm die how do you think this will affect Daenerys' plot?"
So, I'll just answer it like the most non spoilery way possible; I'll say
Tyrion and Jorah are heading back to
Mereen so the plot has to accommodate that.
The show has been teasing us with it
and I think that Tyrion is very important to "A song of ice and fire"
and to Deanerys, so think about the roles
that Barristan and
Grey Worm served in Daenerys' version of the Small Council
in her trust circle of advisers, in
how tyrion might fit into that.
Tyrion is not so great with swords, but he's
great at dealing with big-city problems.
People problems are what Daenerys has
right now, so
she needs Tyrions help whether she knows it or not.
I will say that what the show is doing right now
is vastly different from the books.
Barristan is supposed to have point of view chapters in Winds of Winter.
We're gonna have to wait like another
year for George RR Martin to finish that
book, so we won't be able to compare till then.
Next question: five min asks
I can't understand why Roose Bolton would
want to rebel against the Lannisters right now.
I assume that you are talking about King's Landing and the crown.
Well, he has the bigger army
and he feels like he has the right to
rule.
He seems like a very devout person.
Melisandre has kinda brainwashed him a
little bit; he has drunken the Kool Aid.
She spent the last couple of seasons
telling him that he is destined to rule.
Regardless of whether or not you
agree with her, remember the scene when
Stannis went to get money from the iron
bank so that he could hire his army.
He told them he'd be a much better ruler
than Tommen would ever be,
and I think that's true at least in the
short term we really don't know
what kind of man Tommen is gonna grow up to be,
if he lives to manhood.
Next question: stefan asks
My questions is about Jaime and Bronns'conversation the ship.
do you think he meant what he said about
Tyrion and was it in the books
Well, Jaime and Bronn did not go to Dorne
in the books, so that definitely wasn't in the books,
and I think he felt like he meant what
he said about Tyrion and he seemed genuine.
The problem with Jaime thus far has
been the he lacks conviction.
He's always been really amazing with the blade but now in this season
this is like him trying to take
control of his life.
Old Jaime, like season 1 Jaime, would have just been a bystander in all this.
He would've just stayed King's Landing with Cersei.
I think he still loves Tyrion, but
he did not release Tyrion with the intention of letting him go to kill their father;
so he is pissed about that, because now
there is this big mess in King's Landing,
and their father's not there to fix it.
Whenever they had that scene over his body in Baelor's Sept,
that was what Jaime was talking about.
They're gonna try and tear down everything he did,
everything he built for us.
That's kinda of a meta-term, you know, everything he did for them politically, economically,
so Jaime is pissed now that
his life is in a complete chaos;
alltough it was probably heading in that direction anyway.
So, I think his answer is largely a reaction to that situation
not that he wants Tyrion dead.
Next question: trey asks
do you think that Jon snow will be
legitimized the show
and if so how much longer do you think it'll take?
Well, he's gonna stay true to his vows
till his last breath,
so I don't think he'll ever accept an offer
like that to be legitimized.
What I'd like to see is if Jon Snow's gonna
be endgame,
if he's gonna be like season 7 season 8, you know, battle of fire and ice endgame;
but, I like to see as them reach a truce
and him attain royalty that way.
Like in the shattered runes of westeros
someone has to take charge so hopefully
Deanerys will still be around
and Jon Snow will be around too and they will be somehow part of the bargain that everyone makes
and John will be forced to become a
royal.
They made this big tease about the Melisandre sex scene.
Jon said: "I don't care, I love another,  it doesn't matter."
So, if they're making such a big deal about him not wanting to betray Ygritte's memory
then what would be better then forcing him into a marriage,
just likes sansa is being forced into a marriage.
But, I think something like that, if the
show goes to that place,
will be like season 7 territory.
Right now this season is like Jon being
put through his paces,
and learning what it means to be a ruler.
In my head canon I would love
nothing more than to see him become
the next king of winter though.
Next question: John Norris asks
How much power do targaryen's have over dragons?
If your are a Targaryen will a Dragon know it
or do you have to be around when its
raised from a dragon pup?
Technically no, because if you remember
there a lot of Targaryens historically
that rode Balerion the Black Dread
that were born after he was born.
Balerion is a good example of a dragon that lived for hundreds of years ,so
a lot of Targaryens came and went during
his life.
Usually, according to the books you have
affinity with dragons or you don't,
but I think it's implied
that if you were to hatch and raise a dragon,
as Daenerys is, you would form an even stronger connection.
Like, if Jon Snow secretly turns out to
be part Targaryen
he would have Dragon affinity. We have no
idea how long it's going to be before
he's gonna be anywhere near a dragon though, so we are probably not going to find out anytime soon.
There's a certain amount of loyalty, like
you saw from Drogon, but they have free will.
There's a certain amount of nurture,
certain amount nature in them.
The problem that Daenerys is having
right now is that Rhaegal and Viserion
have been chained and they are super
pissed. They are still connected to her,
but they're enraged at their situation right
now.
Next question: lilith asks
Doesn't it make sense for Varys to seek help from Doran Martell? I think they would support Daenerys.
Well, I think, you know, Prince Doran would probably support Daenerys.
I don't know about the other Sand Snakes.
What I'm hoping we find out is that the
show kinda bends cannon and just like a little bit,
and the Martell's end up being secretly
part of the Targaryen restoration.
Varys made it seem like it was actually
a pretty big movement,
like a big shadow movement, from powerful people behind the scenes.
Without introducing a lot a new characters that we haven't seen yet,
the show has to bring in other characters that it already has as part of that plot.
And how many super powerful, super rich
people have we met on the show
that would want to get rid of the Lannisters
beyond the iron bank.
The Martell's are just, like, really high up on that list.
Next question: LordGaga asks
If Jon knew Sansa was at Winterfell, would he go and fight the Boltons with Stannis?
Well, if you haven't read the books there's
something called the pink letter
that directly addresses this.
It's kind of spoilery so I won't mention
it; but I will say
yes, there are certain things that would
make him break his vows.
All the people from Stannis' camp
have been trying to get Jon Snow to join their cause,
and he's refused them thus far.
So, what I'm hoping is that something happens at the end of the season to change his mind.
We could see a pink letter type twist or
the show could replace it with something similar.
Next question: Ricky asks
Why did Cersei militarized the Faith of the Seven
when she already has a Lannister army and
the Gold Cloaks?
This is actually a really good point
to talk about differences between the
show and the books.
So, the reason that Cersei reinstates the
faith millitant in the books,
is is really logical really important.
On the show, it doesn't make quite as much sense.
In both cases, the crown is out of money,
in super debt to everyone,
including the Church of the Seven.
So, it's possible that show Cersei feels like the gold cloaks are overtaxed doing other things.
They don't have the time to do the things that she wants the sparrows to do.
Getting rid of people that are inconvenient to her, like the Tyrells.
She's trying to neutralize Margaery by sticking it to Loras.
In the books the crown is about a million gold coins in debt to the faith,
so she owes a shitload of money to the church.
Reinstating the Faith millitant
is one of the conditions that the High Sparrow gives her for forgiving the Crown's debt;
so Cersie comes off with this giant win.
She gets rid of, like, a million dollars that they used owe;
so that's a big problem off their shoulders.
But what she doesn't realize now is that
the faith Millitant just start going crazy all over the city.
Cersie creates her own worst nightmare in the Faith millitant,
thinking that she's really solving one of her big problems.
Next question: Intel asks
Who do you think is ruling or left at Dragonstone while Stannis is away?
Well, actually he left people behind to
take care of it while he's away.
The books, you know, kinda go in a
different direction.
Someone laid siege to Dragonstone.
We haven't seen that in the show, so they
might be bypassing that plot.
Really what they're doing is looking for more
gold to pay back their creditors.
Loras is part of that expedition because
Loras is in King's Landing
doing something completely different on the show.
I don't think we're gonna see of that
Dragonstone stuff.
Next question: aidan asks
Do you think we'll ever see
other locations like Asshai
or Yi Ti I'm curious to know what those
parts the world look like.
Yeah. I mean I definitely think that we will
visit other places.
Really what, you know, what happens is
I think, you know, next season we'll just
push deeper into, like, the brand new
places this season like Dorne and Braavos.
But what i'm really hoping the show does is go to the ruins of Valyria.
Right now there's not a huge reason to
do that, not as much reason is to say,
you know, go up to the land of always winter.
That's another place we'll see more of.
But it's almost like each new season
they try to go somewhere new, but it has
to be really important for the plot;
so if the show isn't going to do any of the
Citadel plotline, we might not go to Highgarden.
The same goes for anywhere else, but I do think we'll see more
Old Volantis next season, more lands of
always winter,
more Dorne and more around Slavors Bay.
Thank you so much everyone for submiting  questions. These are always a ton of fun to do.
Generally, I think everyone is a little
more excited about this episode,
just cuz some shit really went down.
It's really once the show starts to
approach, like, the middle of each season
that it really starts to go crazy;
so I am expecting like a steady stream
of WTF moments
from here on out to the end of the season.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway winner too:
red claw 87.
You win an HBO now subscription. Just be
sure to DM me on the on the back end of
channel for contact details.
If there is anything specific you guys want me
to do for my next bonus video,
just be sure to leave request in the comments.
What I'll probably do is another video about Hardholme or maybe another Braavos video.
So while you wait for that stuff to post you
can click here for my episode 4 video
and you can click here for my Star Wars
day bonus video. We learn a little bit
about some the new cast members.
So, thank you so much for watching. Everybody -
lets high five and may the force be with you.